it's described as a once in a lifetime
event nearly 10 inches of rain fell
overnight in New York State's Hudson
Valley that's normally the amount
recorded for the entire summer water
just kept coming up
they got about halfway on my yard and I
went out on the on the road left the
house turned everything off and went on
the road
and then the water just kept coming and
it this is what happened a state of
emergency has been declared these are
unprecedented weather events that keep
hitting us over and over and over again
so we must change our Behavior there was
people that were trapped in their car in
three four feet of water that stayed in
their car those people all needed to be
rescued by EMS police and fire a state
of emergency has also been declared in
the neighboring state of Vermont
sometimes recorded overnight rain of up
to five inches several families needed
to be rescued from the flooding and
emergency teams have been brought in
from other states so far two Swift water
rescue teams from North Carolina are in
the state and we folded into our
operations
another team from Massachusetts is
enroute and we'll be here later today
this is an all Hands-On deck response
the damage to property and
infrastructure is now unavoidable but we
can save lives with simple common sense
and we ask you to exercise that common
sense
apart from the damage to property travel
has been severely disrupted numerous
roads have been flooded or simply washed
away
air traffic from several major airports
were suspended and it's not over yet
rain continues to fall
Mike Hanna Al Jazeera Washington